So I just want to clarify
for everyone watching us
that as a child
you were diagnosed
with an auditory
processing disorder
and a speech impediment.
Can you explain what that is
and how it shaped your life?
Because now
you speak perfectly,
and it's hard to imagine
what you were before,
what your speech
was like before.
Well, I was born early,
along with my twin,
and a lot of times for infants
that can lead
to learning delays.
And so one of my delays
was in speech
and speech pronunciation,
and also just
the auditory processing issue
just means
that I really struggle
as an auditory learner.
But what that also meant
is the learning process
by which at a certain age
kids are saying "R"
and "shh" and "chh,"
those were a lot of the sounds
that I would still
struggle with--
specifically "R" because
it is one of the most complex
letters in
the English alphabet.
That was something
that I would struggle with
until probably
20 years of age.
And when you have
a last name like Gorman,
when you are writing poetry,
all the things
that constitute my identity,
when you go
to a school like Harvard,
which has two Rs in it,
it leads to all of these
kind of road blocks.
But I'm really grateful,
actually, for that experience,
because it informs my poetry
and I think it made me
all that much stronger
of a writer.
When you have to teach yourself
how to say words from scratch,
when you are learning through
poetry how to speak English,
it lent to a great
understanding, I think,
of sound, of pitch,
of pronunciation.
So, I think of
my speech impediment
not as a weakness
or a disability,
but as one of
my greatest strengths.